[Musique]
ouais tu ton coeur est juste si tu
t'entraînes toi aussi tu peux être x man
x men c'est pas ma canne mais alors pas
du tout parce que tout d'abord on m'a
déjà dépuceler
je le protégerai contre câbles mais tout
seul je peux pas je suis à x manager ta
gueule hélas tout et sinon tu recrutes
justin bieber a tu as vu toutes apprises
pour justin bieber était paré ont dit qu
un pouf eux déguisés en jouer tellement
d'arc
tu es sûr que tu viens pas l'univers dc
comics
on est en approche
bref
l'interceptent pouvoir
attention à 15
au revoir ces gamins et sans difficulté
des gages boulot sur la haine la noce
le protégerait contre câble est tout
seul je peux pas faut du renfort
on va former un super méga groupe mais
on va refaire un tour sur linkedin
je te présente des delà je m'appelle
shatter star domino j'ai de la chance la
chance c'est pas super pouvoir écouter
sinon
mais si on n'a qu'à couper la poire en
deux et non aller en piste donc
moi
mexique
départ au syndicat et qui sait en jouer
darques tu es sûr que tu viens pas
l'univers dc comics
[Musique]
willy deux parties
dis donc t'es balles elles sont rapides
maintenant pour couronner le tout peter
un super pouvoir quelconque je sais pas
nager pas de pouvoir non j'ai vu
l'annoncé voilà tel poste
[Musique]